hey 42 here on the 7th of february this
year
in a remote region of the indian
himalayas
a wall of churning water ripped through
a narrow mountain valley
obliterating everything in its path a
brand new power plant
was all but destroyed two hydroelectric
dams were washed away
and several villagers were utterly
devastated
more than 200 lives were taken by the
raging water
flooding isn't all that unusual in the
himalayas during the summer and monsoon
months
there are literally thousands of
glaciers tucked away amongst its jagged
peaks
and warm weather combined with sudden
torrential rain
is a recipe for flash floods but
this particular disaster happened in
february
towards the end of a long freezing
winter
when liquid water isn't really supposed
to be a thing outside of a few
fast-flowing alpine rivers
so how was that possible
official reports put forward a number of
theories about what might have triggered
the flood
including a glacial outburst rogue
landslides
or disturbances caused by industrial
activity in the area
but locals have a theory of their own
one that if correct could have
potentially deadly
implications for hundreds of millions of
people
across india you see the people who live
in this particular valley in the
himalayas
tell stories of a forgotten nuclear
device
hidden amongst the nearby himalayan
peaks
they believe heat given off by this
device
is to blame for the unseasonal flooding
but how exactly do the locals think
such a nuclear device could possibly
have ended up in this remote part of the
himalayas
easy the cia put it there
or to be precise the cia lost it there
during a botched cold war operation
involving some of the world's best
mountain climbers
several kilograms of plutonium and a
liberal amount of improvised blackface
now that probably sounds about as
realistic
and politically correct as the plot from
an old bond film
but believe it or not this particular
cia mission
called operation hat really did take
place during the cold war resulting in
the loss
of seven highly radioactive plutonium
cores at the top of one of the world's
tallest
mountains where so far as anyone knows
they remain to this day the cold war was
defined by a global political climate of
tension
and widespread paranoia perhaps
unsurprisingly such ubiquitous distrust
made this period of history something of
a
golden era for international espionage
and intrigue or to put it another way
during the cold war anyone who was
anyone
was spying on almost everyone in 1965
the united states was paying
particularly close attention to a
certain communist superpower in waiting
china ruled by the infamous chairman mao
at the time china was beginning to flex
its technological muscles
conducting its first nuclear weapons
test in october
of 1964 as part of its two bombs one
satellite program
hold on a minute why does saying two
bombs one satellite make me feel
slightly queasy
weird china's rapid progress in the
development of weapons of mass
destruction
was a worry and the united states was
keen to keep an eye on this
emerging threat one way to do this was
to build a listening post
to intercept telemetry signals being
sent
between chinese test missiles and ground
control
it was a promising idea but considering
the available technology at the time
the listening post would need to be
placed relatively close to the chinese
border
and with a line of sight not obscured by
terrain
the curvature of the earth or anything
else for that matter
luckily the americans knew just a place
india the indians were themselves more
than a little bit nervous about their
northern neighbours
newfound ponchon for nuclear warheads
and so they were all for establishing
the proposed listening station
india also happens to be in possession
of a conveniently giant mountain range
whose peaks offered an uninterrupted
view
well into china the himalayas
with the indians on board nanda devi
the country's second tallest mountain
was chosen
as the perfect location for the
listening post and over in the u.s
operation hat was formed in order to put
it there
by the way if the name nanda devi rings
a bell
you might be remembering it from a
recent video i did on the mysterious
skeletons in roopkund lake
as it turns out the devastating
himalayan flood in february
of this year occurred just 25 kilometers
from rubicon lake
as the crow flies although thinking
about it
the idiom as the crow flies doesn't
really apply here
there's a 7 000 meter mountain peak
between the two points
and crows can't actually fly that high
anyway
as operation hack got underway in 1965
it soon became clear there were going to
be some enormous challenges to overcome
for starters there was no infrastructure
of any kind near nanda devi
which meant the cia's planned listening
station would have to be unmanned
and entirely self-sufficient the biggest
concern
was how to power the station regular
batteries wouldn't have the longevity
even those really expensive ones with
the bunny on and solar panels weren't
really suitable for such a
demanding changeable environment
there was one other option though
nuclear power that might sound kind of
extreme but this was a cold war after
all
plutonium had never been more
fashionable
so a nuclear-powered listening device
complete with seven plutonium cores was
duly built
all that was left was to put it on top
of nanda devi
but that turned out to be a lot easier
said
than done the himalayas are known as
the roof of the world for good reason
they're really bloody big and whilst
flying their device to the top of the
mountain
seemed the obvious choice it simply
wasn't possible
as well as being obscenely tall nanda
devi
is one of the steepest mountains on
earth
landing on it just wasn't going to be an
option
and that meant there was only one thing
for
it the cia were going to have to carry
the 60 kilogram listening device up to 7
800 meter peak the old-fashioned way by
literally carrying it nanda devi is
surrounded on all sides by some of the
world's tallest mountains
including 12 peaks of 6500 meters or so
that's the equivalent of 17 empire state
buildings
piled on top of each other this ring of
mountains creates a kind of
natural shield wall around nanda devi
that's
all but impenetrable think of it like
mordor
except the wall of mountains doesn't
hide an army of orcs
and the giant eye showing all the
symptoms of a nasty case of
conjunctivitis but
a pristine wilderness called the
sanctuary
that's entirely cut off from the outside
world
the sanctuary is so remote and the
terrain around it is
so challenging that it took explorers
almost 100 years
to figure out how to get inside and when
it was
finally breached by two british men and
their free
sherpa companions in 1934 they declared
the journey to be more
challenging than reaching the north pole
and you have to go through all of that
just to get to the base of nanda devi
which rises another 3 000 metres above
the sanctuary
climbing nanda devi was a task so
difficult
that there weren't all that many people
on the entire planet
with the necessary skills experience and
giant steel balls required to even
attempt it
and inconveniently enough none of them
happened to work for the cia
so the bigwigs at langley did the only
thing they could do
under the circumstances they started
covertly recruiting the alpine
equivalent
of the justice league a crack team of
the most gifted mountaineers of their
generation
made up of 14 men from the us and four
from india
between them these men boasted all sorts
of climbing
records and first ascents of the world's
deadliest peaks
but as talented as they were none of
them had all that much experience
dealing with plutonium
which meant one of their number jim
mccarthy
who had a few years earlier become the
first climber
ever to be featured on the front cover
of sports illustrated was given a crash
course
in the safe handling of highly
radioactive material
imagine alex honold star of the film
free
solo being given nuclear training
in order to carry out a top-secret
mission for the american government
in a part of the world only accessible
to a god level climber
and you've pretty much got your head
around the sheer
craziness that was operation hat
incidentally jim mccarthy would go on to
develop testicular cancer
in later life something he believed was
caused by exposure to the plutonium
radiation
during this mad mission but back in 1965
mccarthy his potentially irradiated
balls
and the rest of the justice league of
climbers were on the way to nanda devi's
base camp
in helicopters this particular method of
transport was chosen
so as to give the americans he would
stand out like a sore form in 1960s
india
minimum exposure to the locals if rumors
of the operation had reached chinese
ears
the listening post would have been
completely worthless
the light-skinned members of the
climbing team even went so far as to
artificially darken their skin with
indian tanning lotions
to try and better blend in because
apparently blackface is okay if you're
engaged in cold war espionage
a team of pauses was hired to lug the
equipment
including the nuclear-powered listening
device up to base camp
and a vague story about a stash of gold
was concocted by cia representatives
to explain the presence of a certain
incongruous
60 kilogram solid lead bark stashed away
amongst the food and crampons
not that the porters believed a word of
it they may not have had a huge amount
of experience
porting solid gold but they knew it
didn't give off continuous
intense waves of heat for weeks on end
once the equipment and the climbers were
safely at base camp
operation hat was finally ready to begin
the team began their ascent in clear
weather and made
excellent progress over the course of
almost a month
but when they were just 600 meters from
the summit
a huge storm rolled in making what was
already
an incredibly dangerous climb virtually
impossible the conditions were so bad
the climbers had
no option but to abandon the mission and
turn back they tupped the listening
device securely away in a crevice near
their camp
and made their way back down with plans
to attempt the summit again
when the weather turned at the beginning
of the following season
but when they made it back to the site
of their final camp
several months later the listening
device
was gone in fact the entire area
had been swept away by a combination of
avalanches
and landslides and despite several
recovery expeditions
sent to nanda devi to search for the
device
over the following years no trace of it
was ever seen again
whilst there were a few rumors of agents
from pakistan
sneaking up the mountain over the winter
and nabbing the device
the most popular theory is that it was
dislodged from its hiding place
by natural processes of the mountain and
absorbed into one of nanda devi's
colossal glaciers which brings us back
to the recent winter flooding that
oddly enough just so happens to have
occurred in the exact same
area that a certain rather toasty
nuclear device
went missing in the 60s so
could the unseasonal floods this
february have been caused by the cia's
lost
nuclear device actually
no because whilst at first nobody seemed
quite sure what could have created such
a devastating flood
in the middle of winter satellite
imagery has since proven definitively
that it was caused by a huge section of
rock and ice
breaking away from nanda devi's flank
and
crashing into the river a couple of
kilometers below
but that doesn't mean several kilograms
of plutonium
stuck in the middle of a himalayan
glacier isn't
a big deal because this particular
region of the himalayas
is home to the source of the river
ganges
the world's third largest river and a
natural resource of
incalculable value to india considered
sacred
to hindus the ganges supports the most
heavily populated river basin
of any river in the world with over
650 million people living within its
reach
if the lost nuclear device of nanda devi
was ever to blow its radioactive load
into the headwaters of the ganges
it could cause an environmental disaster
on an apocalyptic
scale so whilst the fate of the lost
nuclear device of nanda devi
remains unknown almost 60 years after
the cia
somehow managed to lose it let's just
hope it stays that way
thanks for watching you can get your
hands on my book stick a flag in it over
on amazon or on audible links to both in
the description below
thank you